naves del ejército chino entre ellas
drones y aviones de combate como de
costumbre china Está realizando sus
maniobras militares en el estrecho de
Taiwán imágenes propagandísticas y
maniobras que pretenden presionar a las
autoridades de taipei que dice seguir de
cerca la situación 47 de estos aviones
cruzaron la línea del estrecho de Taiwán
y entraron en la zona de defensa aérea
de La Isla se trata de la tercera mayor
incursión registrada desde principios de
año china ha realizado más de 1700
ejercicios de este tipo Beijing culpa a
las autoridades taiwanesas de
provocaciones y colisionar con Estados
Unidos el sábado china manifestó su
firme oposición a un proyecto de ley de
defensa estadounidense que permitía
destinar hasta 10 mil millones de
dólares en ayuda militar Taiwán La Isla
aspira a independizarse de su vecino
chino pero Beijing pretende reunificar
su territorio Washington reconoce la
unidad de China pero mantiene estrechos
lazos con Taiwán desde hace décadas las
tensiones aumentaron cuando Nancy pelosi
de la cámara de representantes de
Estados Unidos visitó La Isla a
principios de agosto desde entonces las
relaciones diplomáticas entre Beijing y
Washington se han deteriorado aún más la
presidenta
taiwanesayne convocó Este martes un
consejo de seguridad para estudiar la
posibilidad de reforzar el sistema de
defensa civil de su territorio